five another assault happening on a
teacher and we have word this one is at
foothill high school which is in
henderson we're told that a student has
been arrested sasha loftus is tracking
the story from the campus
we're told the teacher was not
physically hurt here at foothill high
school but sources say the student
arrested for this assault did have a
knife the foothill high school principal
sent out a letter to parents earlier
today saying school police responded to
this in minutes and it did not disrupt
class time the message added that the
school cannot discuss individual student
matters due to privacy laws but added
that this event serves as a reminder
that weapons are not allowed on campus
and the district will pursue legal
action against any students engaging in
violence
this follows an attack on an el dorado
high school teacher just a few weeks ago
the 16 year old student connected to
that case is facing charges for sexual
assault and attempted murder reporting
from henderson tonight sasha loftis live
local now